the handover of Hong Kong from British
control to the People's Republic of
China in 1997 is considered by many to
mark the formal end of the British
Empire as many of you will know Britain
had acquired the island of Millan's
around it during the opium wars against
China in 1842 Britain gained hong kong
in 1860 added Kowloon and Stonecutters
Island to its possessions and in 1898
Britain took out a 99-year lease on
these lands - unlike the leased
territories Hong Kong and Kowloon were
done so in perpetuity and there was no
legal requirement for Britain to return
these lands to China which raises the
question why did Britain also hand over
Hong Kong in 1997 first a bit of context
Japan had briefly occupied Hong Kong
during the Second World War and whilst
Britain had gotten it back from them in
1945 there was no guarantee that they'd
keep it after the Chinese Civil War
ended in 1941 with the Communist victory
there were concerns that it would invade
yet this never happened Britain had
hoped that the communist regime would
eventually collapse and that the
Republic of China now solely in control
of Taiwan would end up running the
country as the Cold War progress the
communist government's position became
much more secure where as Britain's
international position declined as its
Empire disintegrated as the end of the
99 year lease approached Britain's
previous position of we don't deal with
Communists became much more untenable
when Margaret Thatcher became prime
minister in 1979 she had very little
choice except to engage with the Beijing
government the two positions both sides
took were pretty clear China wanted it
all back in 1997 and that was final
Britain was content to hand back the new
territories but wish to continue
administering Hong Kong with Chinese
permission China said no negotiations
between both sides were pretty heated at
points with the Chinese premier Deng
Xiaoping telling Thatcher that he could
simply invade and conquer the island
anytime he wanted to and there would be
nothing that she could do about it one
avenue of potential compromise was
Portugal or more specifically the
Portuguese colony of Macau which Britain
believed could act as an example Macau
was during a cold war still administered
by Portugal but only with Chinese
consent a point this idea was floated by
and rejected by both sides because it
did little more than kick the can down
the road to make matters slightly more
complicated there were many protests
across the colony against continued
British rule some of these were
pro-beijing communist protests which
were organized by trade unions with the
ultimate goal of rejoining China some
were simply protest which demanded
greater autonomy as well as more
democratic right
whilst also making it clear that they
didn't think that Maoism sounded like
fun furthermore Britain and also China
were faced by what's known as the Hong
Kong man the Hong Kong man was the
manifestation of Hong Kong nationalism
and the notion that the people there
weren't British and they also weren't
Chinese but instead with their own
people with their own way of life it was
this movement which occurred in the wake
of the Tiananmen Square crackdown which
saw Britain introduced wide sweeping
democratic reforms in the colony in the
end though the clock was ticking China
was patiently waiting and Britain had to
decide what was going to happen to Hong
Kong proper and its people when the
lease of the territories expired
thus Thatcher in the British government
were left with only one option retreat
from China since there was no hope of
them retaining it under any
circumstances as such Britain conceded
to China's demands and pledged to return
the island to China but in doing so they
wanted certain guarantees in the end
trying to agree to maintain Hong Kong's
capitalist economic system and its
people's rights and privileges for at
least 50 years and for Britain this was
frankly as much as it was ever going to
get after the Second World War in the
decline of British influence the future
of Hong Kong was decided in Beijing not
London the Chinese government had to do
nothing but wait for 1997 to come around
was making it clear that all of
Britain's territories in the region
would be returned Britain could neither
negotiate any continuation of
sovereignty nor could it defeat a power
half a world away and in the end Britain
handed over Hong Kong for one simple
reason he had no choice I hope you
enjoyed this episode and thank you for
watching with extra thanks to my patrons
that you see on screen now and a special
thanks to James Bissonnette izalco flash
mark H party-boy Co David archaeologist
Rob Waterhouse Chris wicker Michael
Reynolds Gustav Swan onion Duck David
Silverman Paul Maggie packs Kowski
Winston K wood vasily era vedas
christian check hey anthony Beckett sky
Chappell Adam Harvey and Ike